قاعدين في في الخيمه اجت الريح زي ما انت
شايف طيب الخيمه والميه نزلت علينا قضينا
لتنا لجانا على الجامع اخذنا فشنا كله ميه
ونمنا على الارض في
الجامع هك شايف يا خيي كيف حالنا لسه هدول
الصغار في بعض منهم راحوا على الحمامات
قوم نايمين فوق بعضنا وعنا هي بنت رضيعه
ان ولدت في الحرب امها ولدتها قيصري لا
لاقين لها اواعي ولا حليب ولا بمبرز
والوضع صعب زي ما انت شايف الاولاد شايف
كيف ه يعني الشي بكي لحاله شايف الوضع
كيف حالنا مرم هان وهي الدار كلها رمل جوا
رمل وبرا رمل ولا عارفين وين نجلي ولا
عارفين نجيب ميه ولا نحصل حاجه يعني ايش
بدي اقوللك الوضع صعب يعني طيب ايش سويتوا
الليله في الشتا
هذا كربنا فوق بعضينا بنا نطلع برا مش
قادرين طلع الميه لابسه على باب الدار
يعني مش قادرين نحط رجلين الارض طينه
طلعنا بعيد عنك الله يعزك النعز تبعنا
بلزق في الارضيه يعني وضع صعب جدا وربنا
العالم بالحال الشكوه غير ربنا الواحد
يقول الحمد لله علمنا الله روح
روح